nel 1954 in un tanto tempo fa in un
paesino
dell'entroterra savonese e sono
cresciuto libero nei boschi già coi
tempi mia madre avrebbe voluto che io
diventassi prete ma all'epoca i preti
avevano la tonnac lunga con tantissimi
bottoni e questo non mi piaceva molto
poi facendo il liceo classico di nuovo
mia madre avrebbe preferito che io
diventassi medico ma io invece Scelsi
ingegneria perché avevo visto una
immagine una comunicazione che diceva
che l'ingegneria può aiutare il mondo e
non è questo mi era piaciuto molto
finito il Politecnico a Torino E iniziai
subito a lavorare in aziende Ma già dopo
qualche anno le cose non andavano molto
bene io mi impegnavo molto però non mi
quadravano i conti e quindi per fortuna
avevo cominciato a studiare psicologia e
quindi ero riferimento alla conoscenza
che tutta la realtà col mondo esterno
viene mediata dal cervello viscerale o
secondo cervello secondo cervello
abbiamo un cervello nella pancia la cosa
mi aveva completamente cambiato la vita
e mentre prima io mi impegnavo tanto e
mi buttavo nel lavoro ma senza
ascoltarmi Senza tenere conto di quello
che poteva essere il rapporto con gli
altri con l'ambiente e con la situazione
come penso facciano tanti Immagino che
anche voi sarà successo di entrare in
una stanza in un ambiente e provare
delle sensazioni sgradevoli e non dovute
a dei cattivi odori oppure andare a un
incontro a un appuntamento O leggere o
fare un qualcosa e di fatto
Vi si blocca subito oppure dovete
Scusate Dovete affrontare un argomento
difficile di quelli un po' un po'
scottanti E allora è di colpo Vi si
blocca lo stomaco oppure vi viene un
nodo alla gola Oppure viene un mal di
testa Ecco questo è chiaramente una una
segnalazione che vi arriva dal cervello
viscerale che vi dice che quello che
state facendo non è esattamente una cosa
a vostro a vostro vantaggio Fin
dall'antichità la pancia è sempre stata
considerata come la sede principale dei
sentimenti e delle emozioni alcuni modi
di dire di pancia Direi di sì si intende
distinto Di impulso oppure sentire le
farfalle nella pancia quando si è
innamorati oppure quando si dice la
prima idea è quella giusta ma noi in
genere facciamo la seconda Per studiarlo
è stata creata è nata la neuro
Gastroenterologia e i risultati del
della Ricerca Scientifica già dalla metà
1800 è il tedesco Leopold Auerbach aveva
riscontrato con il microscopio la
presenza di una rete neuronale ma è poi
dal 1998 che in effetti si comincia a
prendere seriamente in considerazione
l'ipotesi di un secondo cervello con
mica il gerson della Columbia University
che scrive che pubblica un libro dal
titolo il secondo cervello l'unico
organo che contiene un sistema nervoso
Il sistema nervoso enterico quasi
autonomo alcuni numeri è sì alcuni
numeri
l'intestino lungo circa 8 metri e
contiene il 70-80% delle delle cellule
immunitarie e ospita il microbiota che
sarebbe la flora intestinale e che a sua
volta è composto da 100 mila miliardi di
microbi e che pesa un chilo quindi
prestate un po' tutte queste cose sono
all'interno della nostra pancia e che ha
soprattutto una funzione di difesa e di
supporto al sistema immunitario inoltre
ha una struttura diciamo a
corrugata e un centimetro cubo se
potesse essere veramente aperto
completamente potrebbe coprire una
superficie di circa 500 metri quadri
pari a quasi due campi da tennis e
pensate che a lungo 670 cm quindi il
totale viene fuori un numero spaventoso
tale da coprire si ipotizza quasi 40
campi da calcio veramente un numero
elevatissimo
quindi
oltre ad avere tutte queste cose qui
nella nostra pancia Noi abbiamo nel
nostro corpo distribuite nel nostro
corpo un numero veramente molto grande
di antenne che ci segnalano
continuamente informazioni dall'esterno
tramite 5 sensi Quindi la vista l'udito
l'odorato il gusto e il tatto e il
sistema nervoso quello che è quello che
è importante considerare perché
noi abbiamo questa comunicazione perché
abbiamo tutta una parte di emozione
viscerale che non viene mediata tramite
il pensiero razionale ma diciamo Passa
direttamente senza proprio passare al
pensiero razionale esempio se noi
vediamo una rosa e la annusiamo il
profumo entra dappertutto oppure
le emozioni che dà una carezza oppure
tutte quelle che sono le emozioni
veramente viscerali tutto detto questo
passa tramite Senza passare dal pensiero
razionale vediamo un cibo che ci piace
moltissimo e immediatamente ci viene
all'acquolina in bocca oppure la mattina
quando ci prepariamo a fare il caffè
apriamo il barattolo sentiamo quel buon
profumo immediatamente sentiamo il gusto
del caffè in bocca Quindi c'è tutta una
situazione che effettivamente ci porta
delle emozioni il cervello cerebrale non
ha questa capacità e mentre invece il
bello della vita il passa proprio
attraverso il viscerale e
di recente ancora La ricerca è continua
e Nel 2020 è stato anche causa della
pandemia è stato pubblicato da un
gastroenterologo italiano di fama
internazionale del professor Silvio
Danese ha pubblicato due libri la pancia
lo sa e la
pancia lo sa e ti piace la pancia e con
il quale fondamentalmente dice che
tutte le informazioni arrivano dalla
pancia che noi conosce delle cose che
noi assolutamente non non sappiamo e che
dovremmo imparare proprio dalla pancia
Quindi dovremo andare a scuola dalla
pancia
è il cervello viscerale come dicevo non
ha queste conoscenze però dal viscerale
passa Il Gusto della Vita il viscerale È
come un bambino interiore che segue i
profumi i sapori i colori esattamente
con la stessa intensità e ingenuità e
tutto soprattutto dal gusto alla vita
allora
mettendo assieme il fatto che abbiamo un
secondo cervello che abbiamo un sistema
di comunicazione interno vastissimo e
che noi impattiamore all'esterno con il
nostro corpo Quindi questa questa
questo metodo questa questa conoscenza
che io utilizzo per la mia attività e
che aumenta sempre di più diciamo con la
con la pratica ha portato molti benefici
sia a me sia quelli a cui la insegno si
impara Come leggere e scrivere si impara
Come leggere e scrivere veramente e ed è
un percorso meraviglioso che io oggi ho
avuto il piacere di presentarvi qui e di
dividere con voi come conoscenza e
allora se
vi ha incuriosito quello che vi ho
raccontato Allora vi invito veramente ad
ascoltarvi e mettere in relazione quello
che provate con quello che state facendo
magari state andando un appuntamento
oppure state leggendo un giornale e
giusto per fare un esempio magari cioè
viene da un prurito e vi grattati in
maniera energica Senza neanche pensarci
Allora fate attenzione fermatevi un
attimo e provate a pensare che forse
quel prurito quello a quel disagio
quella situazione che che avvertite non
è dovuta magari a una situazione reale
ma è potrebbe essere una informazione
che vi arriva dal cervello viscerale e
quindi in questo caso dovreste anche
capire che magari il cervello di salario
vi sta dicendo che state facendo una
cosa che non vi è utile che magari state
perdendo tempo quindi c'è tutto un mondo
di diciamo di informazione che tutto
quanto viene mediato dal nostro cervello
viscerale dalla nostra pancia Allora io
vi invito appunto a fare attenzione alle
relazioni e alle reazioni che voi avete
e mi auguro che anche a voi si apra un
mondo di conoscenza
utile per me oggi è di pancia di così
[Applauso]